the supreme court rules seven to two to
uphold obamacare and votes unanimously
to protect a catholic foster care
service
but on the narrowest possible grounds
and congress declares juneteenth the
national holiday in bipartisan fashion
but the left
is fighting mad about it i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben get to all the news in just one
moment first your reminder you're
spending way too much on your cell phone
bill if you have anything except for
pure talk
usa i know a lot of my listeners already
know this because another thousand of
you my extremely wise listeners
have made the switch from your
overpriced wireless carrier to peer talk
over the past couple of months
what exactly are the rest of you waiting
for if you're with atv verizon or
t-mobile your family could save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers you can even keep your
phone and your number but
you're going to save a fortune by the
way pure talk is the top-rated wireless
company by consumer affair they've got
the absolute best customer service team
based right here in america and if it
sounds good it gets even better because
right now
you can get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for 30 bucks a month
30 bucks a month and you're saying to
yourself well what if i use eight gigs
of data here's the thing if you go over
on the data pure talk usa is not going
to charge you for it a lot of phone
companies will sort of
intentionally confuse you as what you
are getting not so with pure talk
usa get started today grab your mobile
phones i'll pound 250 say
my name ben shapiro when you do you'll
save 50
off your very first month tile pound 250
say keyword
ben shapiro to get started pure talk is
simply smarter wireless
alrighty so yesterday the supreme court
came down with a couple of
big decisions both were were somewhat
expected
both were i would say disappointments
for
conservatives and you're seeing some
conservatives today spin these decisions
as not super disappointing for
conservatives but they they're
disappointing for conservatives
one of them less so than the other so
the first one
was sort of expected there was a case
that was brought to the supreme court
the case was basically that obamacare
ought to be struck down
in its entirety which of course would
throw the healthcare system into a bit
of a mess considering that obamacare has
now been implemented in the united
states for nia on a decade
and that means that it would undo a lot
of what's already been done
in terms of public in terms of obamacare
options available and number of people
who are already on obamacare options and
subsidies schemes that have been created
now the reality when it comes to
obamacare is that obamacare has not been
the sort of panacea that everybody on
the left suggested it was going to be
it has not been sort of the end of the
world as some of us thought that it
would be but it certainly has not
succeeded in bringing down the price of
health care overall megan mcardle over
at the washington post has a very good
piece
on this she points out that some of her
critiques she's a big
critic of obamacare some of those
critiques were right some of them were a
little bit overblown she was first i
doubted we would improve our overly
complex balkanized healthcare system
with yet another major program
that would make it even more complicated
second i feared committing more than 100
billion dollars to new spending every
year
at a time when we hadn't even figured
out how to pay for existing entitlement
programs
third i worried that having the
government subsidize even more of our
medical bills would lead to price
pressure
particularly on pharmaceuticals and
medical devices which in turn would
reduce incentives for innovation
and fourth i simply didn't believe many
of the claims supporters were making
explicitly or implicitly about obamacare
dramatically reducing healthcare costs
or bankruptcies or infant mortality or
improving lifespans
so the the complications of the
healthcare system remain
complications right so she was right
about that
the con the system has not gotten any
simpler for pretty much anybody
also with regard to innovation
innovation continues to happen in the
american healthcare system that is
largely the result of the american
healthcare system still
after obamacare being more privatized
than european healthcare
systems and also due to the fact that we
provide pretty serious patent protection
for our drug and pharmaceutical
manufacturers
now obviously there are attempts to roll
that back and to
allow the american health care system to
bargain collectively with pharmaceutical
makers and you've seen the biden
administration try to crack down even
further on innovation by doing things
like
getting rid of patent protection for
mrna vaccines that just saved the world
from this pandemic
as far as the fiscal crisis yes
obamacare costs a lot of money also we
are spending more money than god anyway
is the point that megan mckarl's making
but the the final sort of concern which
is that
this wasn't going to bring down costs
that is exactly right
and as megan mccarter points out
obamacare supporters talked a lot about
illnesses contributing to more than half
of all bankruptcies which implied there
should have been a sharp decrease in
when obamacare took effect there was not
also
infant mortality has not decreased it's
pretty much the same
also obamacare supporters claimed that
tens of thousands of people were dying
every year
because they didn't have health
insurance and that suggested that by
our mortality rate should be
substantially lower instead mortality
rates actually leveled off around the
time of obamacare they said that they
were going to reduce health care costs
and that didn't happen either okay so
bottom line is obamacare hasn't done
much except
adds to the costs and adds to the
complications okay the one thing that
obamacare really did
is it again shifted the nature of the
balance between the government
and the american citizen this is the
problem with the original obamacare
supreme court decision and obamacare in
its essence which is
before this there was no notion in
american law before obamacare there was
no notion in american law really
that the government could punish you for
living and not doing something the
government wanted you to do
right typically you would have to
violate a law but now thanks to
obamacare
the federal government could mandate
that you purchase a product right that
was the new thing
the federal government getting into the
business of forcing you to purchase a
product
now you'll remember that the federal
congress does not have the power to do
that the
federal government has the power to tax
but the federal government does not have
the power to issue some sort of
penalty fee for you not buying a product
which is why the original obamacare case
was twisted by john roberts who is
truly a bad chief justice is twisted by
john roberts
in order so that obamacare be preserved
the way he did this is he completely
rewrote obamacare law and he suggested
that obamacare itself was not a penalty
right there was no patent the individual
mandate was not a penalty attaching
if you didn't buy obamacare or have
health insurance instead
obamacare was a tax right the individual
mandate wasn't a mandate it was a tax
it wasn't a fee it was a tax because the
government has the power to tax and
the people who criticized this said well
it doesn't say anywhere in the lost
attacks the people who are arguing in
favor of the individual mandate
explicitly said it was not a tax
and not only that what sort of tax
applies only to people who do x
or to do why right that doesn't that
doesn't make any sense taxes typically
apply to an entire spectrum of activity
right they they apply to anybody who
owns it property taxes apply if you own
a house
here you're getting a tax if you don't
do something the government wants you to
do which is really weird that's
normally like a penalty okay so the
original obamacare decision was a
travesty of justice
it was originally and then there's a
second case that was brought against
obamacare and it pointed out
that obamacare's language had been
explicitly designed
to provide subsidies for a particular
state but not
the federal not via the federal
government okay and it was a little bit
complex but the bottom line is
that it was actually a pretty good claim
the supreme court threw that out also in
order to preserve obamacare because
again
chief justice john roberts believes that
his sole role
in the american governing system is to
quote unquote preserve the legitimacy of
the supreme court what this has meant in
practice
is preserving heavy pieces of
legislation that are left-wing status
quo
and then curbing any sort of judicial
pushback
to the legislative overreach of the left
right so whenever there's a left-wing
decision that that really preserves a a
large piece
of legislation then john roberts is on
board because he doesn't believe
in quote-unquote judicial activism now
he has redefined judicial activism to
mean something different than it
actually means judicial activism
typically means that you are reading
your own priorities into the law
john roberts has redefined that to mean
any time the supreme court overrules
congress on a major issue
this is quote unquote judicial activism
which is silly literally the job of the
supreme court if you believe in judicial
review
is to overrule the congress when the
congress is in conflict with the
constitution
john roberts believes that when the
judiciary is in conflict with the
legislature as a general rule that's a
bad thing for the judiciary
and therefore you can constantly find
him trying to uphold
very controversial pieces of legislation
up to including obamacare simply by
rewriting the laws
so when it comes to the left he wants to
preserve the law in order to quote
unquote preserve the supreme court when
it comes to
decisions on the right you will find him
seeking unanimity
rather than creating wide sweeping
decisions that actually protect liberty
so instead
he will attempt to go for a 9-0 decision
that limits the scope of liberty
instead of going for like a 6-3 decision
in which he would be in the majority
that expands the scope of liberty okay
so we'll get to that part of john
roberts and what he did yesterday in
just
one second because again i think john
roberts was a terrible pick i was one of
the few
conservative commentators in america who
suggested when john roberts was picked
that he would
that he would in fact be a bad pick i
said alito was going to be good
i thought gorsuch was going to be better
than he has been so far i i thought that
that barrett is an excellent pick i was
going to wish you washington kavanaugh
but robert
i actually just opposed straight out at
the very beginning okay and there's a
reason for that so we'll get to the rest
of this obamacare case and what exactly
happened
yesterday because it was sort of a
bizarre decision against 7-2 we'll get
to that in just one moment first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
again reality is
my kids wake me up all the damn time
this morning it was my son
who popped into my room a little after 6
a.m
and he is very cute so i could not get
upset with him but what does this mean
it means
that the times when i'm on the mattress
i value that sleep and that means i need
to be asleep when i'm on that mattress i
can't be tossing and turning because
it's uncomfortable this is why i value
my personalized made for me helix sleep
mattress helix sleep has a quiz
it takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you get a
mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks so if you are looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you match to mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free you
don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again
helix is great you don't need to take my
word for it helix is awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2020
by both gq and wired magazine
just head on over to helixsleep.com take
that two minutes sleep quiz they'll
match you to the best mattress of your
life 10-year warranty try it out for 100
nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for if you don't
love it you'll love it no risk here
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helix sleep.com ben
best deal of the year 200 bucks off all
mattress orders two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com
ben all right so this obamacare decision
there is a
so basically the the congress under
donald trump in 2017 republicans
controlled congress and you'll remember
there was this big fight
over whether to repeal obamacare i
remember john mccain standing up there
and giving the thumbs down and left
cheering and all of that well one thing
congress did do
is they effectually got rid of the
individual mandate the way they got rid
of the individual mandate which
creates all sorts of problems for the
funding of obamacare generally because
if you can't punish people
for not getting obamacare then why
exactly would they get obamacare in the
first place
right that really was a big question
what congress did is they took the
individual
mandate quote unquote tax down to zero
dollars
now this provided sort of a problem
because if the idea from the supreme
court is that obamacare's individual
mandate was not a fee was not a penalty
it was a tax then once you take the tax
down to zero
it's no longer a tax okay well if it's
no longer a tax
then the entire funding mechanism for
the bill sort of tends to fall apart or
at least part of the funding mechanism
tends to fall apart and the argument
states we're making
is that that provision of the bill this
this quote tax
which makes the bill constitutional is
no longer effectual right there is no
tax anymore so there is no
actual way for the bill to be
constitutional
okay so this was the issue before the
supreme court seems sort of technical
and it is in fact sort of technical so
technical in fact that the reason this
decision is 7-2
is because justice thomas who of course
is the most conservative member of the
court the most originalist member of the
court
and the seminal figure in american legal
thinking
right i'm a bigger fan of justice thomas
than i was even in justice scalia i like
scalia a lot i think thomas
is a superior justice in in a variety of
ways
in fact if you want to know more about
justice thomas on a personal level you
should go check out a brand new
documentary
that we have over at daily wire right
now streaming
created equal and go check that out
we'll talk about that a little bit later
on in the program because it really is
great but
justice thomas he uh he put out a
concurrence
he ruled in favor of holding obamacare
here why
he acknowledges full well that the
states are correct that once you get rid
of the individual mandate tax
that the tax itself is no longer
operative and once it's no longer
operative the entire bill
could theoretically become non-operative
right he he agrees with this basic
argument
so here's what justice thomas writes in
his dissent or rather in his concurrence
he says according to the government the
mandate was quote necessary to make
other reforms effective
it noted that congress's findings
expressly state that enforcement of
those provisions without a minimum
coverage provision would restrict the
availability of health insurance and
make it less affordable
the opposite of congress's goals in
enacting the affordable care act
it was widely thought that without the
mandate much of the act and perhaps even
the whole scheme would collapse
this court also embraced that view when
we re-encountered the act in 2015.
that was another case this is the second
case i talked about where they held
obamacare
where they redefined the state to mean
state or federal government
the court explained that congress had
found that the guaranteed issue
and community rating requirements would
not work without the mandate
but times have changed in this suit the
plaintiffs assert this would be the
obama administration and their
and and their uh well actually this
would be the states that are they're
suing to get rid of
the individual mandate and and the
obamacare entirely
in this suit the plaintiffs assert the
mandate is unconstitutional because it
no longer imposes financial consequences
and thus cannot be justified as a tax
given that the mandate is
unconstitutional other portions of the
act that actually harm the plaintiffs
must fall with it
now the current administration contends
the mandate can in fact be severed from
the rest of the act
okay but here's the bottom line bottom
line is that what justice thomas finds
well he says that the
the plaintiffs here have a pretty good
case that the entire act is
unconstitutional
they don't actually have standing in
order to bring the case so standing as
we've spoken about on the program before
standing is a doctrine that says that
you can only sue
to get rid of a law if the law has done
you some damage if the law has done you
some harm
so if a bus were to hit one of my
producers i cannot sue you for that it
has not harmed me personally
my producer's family could sue but i
can't sue i don't have standing
same thing here so basically thomas says
if you get rid of the the individual
mandate to the extent that there's a
zero
zero dollar tax there's effectively
no damage done to the state so the state
can't actually sue the states
instead sort of kind of but didn't
really make the argument that the whole
act
hurts them and so if you can use this as
a lever to get rid of the whole act that
gives you standing he rejects that
standing argument so that's the
obamacare decision
okay and the obamacare decision again
not totally unexpected even people on
the right
sort of thought that the the case itself
was somewhat weak
that's not where i think the real
disappointment is not really in this
case upholding obamacare
again the big cases against obamacare
were brought in 2000 2012
and those cases were rejected by the
roberts supreme court on really flimsy
grounds
the real disappointment that i have is
for a decision that conservatives
supposedly won
this brings us to the second decision a
lot of conservatives yesterday were very
excited about this decision
i am far less sanguine about this
position and this is the decision where
i am super ticked off
at john roberts okay so the case which
we have discussed briefly on the show
before
this is a case in which there is an
anti-descript so-called
anti-discrimination law
in philadelphia and that
anti-discrimination law basically says
that no contractor with the
city government of philadelphia is
allowed to discriminate on the basis of
sexual orientation
right that is what the law says okay and
this comes into conflict pretty clearly
with catholic adoption and foster
agencies
so catholic adoption and foster agencies
you're
a 16 year old catholic girl you get
pregnant you have a baby on a wedlock
you want to give it up for adoption or
you want to put it in foster care but
you want
the family that adopts to have the same
principles that you hold religiously
and so you want that baby to be fostered
by
a male female married couple which
until like literally the last five
minutes pretty much was considered the
norm in american life
and pretty much throughout the world
right was that a baby needs a mother and
a father this was considered an
extremely uncontroversial statement for
nearly all of human history was that a
baby needed
a mother and a father okay now it is
considered discriminatory if you say
that a baby needs
a mother and a father or that a mother
father married couple should be
preferred
to any other form of family formation
whether you're talking about two men two
women
two brothers uh uh two sisters a single
woman
a single man or any other form of family
that if all other things being equal
right and that's always the key
all other factors being held equal you
prefer a male female couple because a
child needs a mother and father
okay so catholic adoption agencies and
foster agencies still hold by this
this led the city of philadelphia to
basically
suggest that they would no longer do
work with catholic foster agencies
in fact catholic foster agencies would
not be allowed to warp because
they have to work with child protective
services and the city they would no
longer be allowed to operate in the city
limits basically of philadelphia
because they preferred male female
couples male male or female female or
single female or single male couple
families so this was elevated to the
supreme court
on religious freedom grounds right the
idea being
that this is a basic violation of
religious freedom which it very
very clearly is the court ruled mine
nothing in favor of the catholic
adoption agency and foster agency so why
am i pissed off the reason i'm pissed
off is the grounds of the decision
because as always with the robbers court
he prefers unanimity and narrowness
over a divided court with a broad ruling
and that's a serious problem for future
precedent
so here is how cnbc reports this
the supreme court on thursday delivered
a unanimous defeat to lgbt couples in a
high profile case over whether
philadelphia could refuse to contract
with a roman catholic adoption agency
that says its religious beliefs
prevented from working with same-sex
foster parents
chief justice john roberts wrote in an
opinion for a majority of the court that
philadelphia violated the first
amendment by refusing to contract with
catholic social services
once it learned the organization would
not certified same-sex couples for
adoption
roberts wrote the free exercise clause
of the first amendment applicable to
states under the 14th amendment provides
congress shall make no law prohibiting
the free exercise
of religion as an initial matter it is
plain that the city's actions have
burdened
css religious exercise by putting it to
the choice of curtailing its mission or
approving
relationships inconsistent with its
beliefs
so the question in this case is whether
the supreme court was going to
overrule another supreme court decision
that was called employment division
versus smith is a very famous supreme
court decision in which actually justice
scalia wrote the decision and he set a
standard for
whether a law conflicts with religious
freedom how we rule
i believe in that case if i'm not
mistaken i believe the case
was that there was a drug law and it
came into conflict with
a native american religious group that
used peyote as some sort of hallucinogen
in their religious practice and what he
said is a law of neutral
applicability that affects religious
people differently is not in fact a
violation of freedom of religion
now the problem with that basic concept
and conservatives have been sort of up
in arms with employment division versus
smith ever since
since 1990 was that this actually
treats freedom of religion differently
than any other freedom in the american
constitution
because the reality is that every other
freedom of the american constitution we
don't say that if there's a law of
neutral applicability and it just
happens to infringe
on your freedom in this particular area
well you know so be it so for example
if we said that there's an
anti-discrimination law and this
anti-discrimination law
prohibits discrimination in any field of
endeavor
it also happens to infringe on your
ability
to say a thing right it infringes on
your ability
to to speak freely we would have to have
a pretty serious first amendment
discussion as to what level of
anti-discrimination law is applicable
there right
this holds true let's say that there was
a law that just
was was intended on cracking down on
on the ability to disseminate
particular types of printed material and
a crackdown on free press
okay we would make sure there was a
pretty big carve out there for freedom
of the press
but when it comes to freedom of religion
we're going to treat that just as as
though there's no extra stake
for the us government in preserving
freedom of religion as opposed to
anything else in american life
that obviously is not true okay there
there's like employment division versus
smith has been a very controversial case
for a very long time and the standard
scalia sets there
is not one that really comports with the
original meaning of the constitution
and i rarely say that about scalia but i
really think that's true in employment
division versus smith
justice thomas tends to feel the same
way and so
here is the problem with this particular
decision it does not take on
employment division versus smith instead
what it did is decide this case on
extremely narrow grounds
so roberts said that the city's
non-discrimination policy was not
generally applicable instead of him
saying
generally applicable non-discrimination
policies still have to make carve-outs
for religion instead of him saying that
which would be understandable
and would have been much more protective
of religious freedom instead what robert
said
is he sort of gamed it he said well you
know this particular policy
is not a in a neutral policy
this one is so if they made it in
neutral policy maybe they could crack
down on religion
but since it's not really a neutral
policy they can't crack down on religion
they did the exact same thing justice
roberts did the exact
same thing in the jack phillips
masterpiece cake shop
case and people on the right were sure
oh it's great and i was very critical of
that decision because i said here is the
problem
in that case very similar case there's
an anti-discrimination law in the state
of colorado it was brought against jack
phillips who again is now being
subjected
to actual discrimination in the state of
colorado on the basis of religion day in
and day out in that particular case the
master
peace cake shop case jack phillips was
told by a
gay couple that they they wanted him to
bake a cake for their gay wedding
and he said listen i'm happy to sell you
a cake i'm happy to
provide you a cake just as gay people
but i'm not going to participate in a
gay wedding because i'm a religious
christian
and they sued and the supreme court
instead of saying
he has a religious right to practice his
religion
instead of them saying that very clearly
instead what they said is well the way
that the colorado human rights
commission adjudicated the case
demonstrated that they had animus for
him but if they didn't demonstrate the
unanimous for him then maybe they could
have forced him to make the cake
okay which again does not protect
religious rights and it's the same
thing here okay justice roberts was
successful in curtailing
this decision down to its narrowest
possible scope
so that he could get kagan and sotomayor
and briar on board
who gives a crap about getting a 9-0
decision
hey anybody who is concerned with
constitutional principle should be far
less concerned with getting a 9-0
decision that quote-unquote upholds the
integrity of the court than they should
be
with preserving religious freedom rights
under the first amendment to the
constitution
and that's why i'm kind of fighting mad
over this particular decision
robert said no matter the level of
deference we extend to the city the
inclusion of a formal system of entirely
discretionary exceptions
in its foster care standards renders the
contractual non-discrimination
requirement
not generally applicable so again he's
just making excuses
and this is what he does he makes
excuses to uphold government power
and when he strikes down government
power he does on very narrow grounds
that basically still upholds
governmental power he's a bad chief
justice i'm going to bring you some of
the defense in this case in just one
second because they're quite important
we'll get to that momentarily first
let's talk about the fact that right now
propaganda is being rammed down
on your kids by children's networks
disney plus
is doing pride material for small
children you have nickelodeon doing
pride material for small children gay
pride material for small children again
these are small children these are not
18 year olds
what you need is a place that you can
plop your kids
in front of a of a screen if you want
them to watch tv
and actually get good material about the
united states and decent traditional
moral values for kids this is where
prageru comes in prageru has now
launched a massive k-12 education
program
thousands of educators and parents have
already signed up check it out at
prageru.com forward slash kids
prageru has tons of free kids shows
books magazines with the pro-american
values that aren't being taught in
schools or most kids chose
the prageru website has everything you
need to get your young family through
what's happening in our country right
now
you want your kids to learn about our
nation's founding principles and be
proud of them how about passing on
values you care about like truth freedom
responsibility
hard work equality under god if you want
your kids consuming content that
actually supports your values
go to prageru right now show your
children their animated shows books and
magazines
most importantly support prageru in
their efforts to take back america's
education
subscribe now don't miss prague's
incredible free kids content visit
preview.com
kids today we appreciate prageru they
are basically a sister company and um
and they are doing terrific terrific
work okay so as i say
this decision on religious freedom is
extremely
extremely narrow and it's a problem so
justice alito
writes a dissent in this case it's a
concurrence i keep saying to him it's a
concurrence
in which he says this is way too narrow
he says this case
presents an important constitutional
question that urgently calls out for
review
whether this court's governing
interpretation of a bedrock
constitutional right
the right to free exercise of religion
is fundamentally wrong and should be
corrected
in employment division versus smith the
court abruptly pushed aside nearly 40
years of precedent and held that the
first amendment free exercise clause
tolerates any rule that categorically
prohibits or commands
specified conduct so long as it does not
target religious practice
even if a rule serves no important
purpose and has a devastating effect on
religious freedom the constitution
according to smith provides no
protection
this severe holding is ripe for
re-examination so what they were saying
is we basically had six justices who
were ready to overrule employment
division versus smith
we were ready to do it we were ready to
go back to the
the i believe the so-called lemon test
in which we actually examined
whether religious practice came into
conflict with neutral
law and carved out exceptions for
religious practice
there's no question says alito that
smith's interpretations can have
startling consequences here are a few
examples
suppose that the volstead act which
implemented the pro prohibition
amendment had not contained
an exception for sacramental wine the
act would have been consistent with
smith even though it would have
prevented the celebration of a catholic
mass anywhere in the united states
or supposed that a state following the
example of several european countries
made it unlawful to slaughter an animal
that had not first been rendered
unconscious that law would be fine under
smith even though it would outlaw both
kosher and halal slaughter
or suppose that a jurisdiction in this
country following the recommendations
medical associations in europe
banned the circumcision of infants the
san francisco ballot initiative in 2010
proposed just that
a categorical ban would be allowed by
smith even though it prohibited an
ancient and important jewish and muslim
practice
or suppose that this court or some other
court enforced a rigid rule prohibiting
attorneys from
wearing any form of head covering in
court this rule would satisfy smith
even though it would stop orthodox
jewish men seek men and many muslim
women from appearing
many other examples could be added
we may hope that legislators and others
with rulemaking authority will not go as
far as smith allows but the present case
shows the dangers posed by smith are not
hypothetical the city of philadelphia
has issued an
ultimatum to an arm of the catholic
church either engage in conduct that the
church views as contrary to the
traditional christian understanding of
marriage
or abandon a mission that dates back to
the earliest days of the church
providing for the care of orphaned and
abandoned children many people says
alito believe
they have a religious obligation to
assist such children choosing christians
regardless is a scriptural command
it is a mission that the catholic church
has undertaken since ancient times
in the new world religious groups
continued to take the lead the first
known orphanage in what is the united
states was founded by an order of
catholic nuns in new orleans around 1729
during the latter part of the 19th
century and continuing into the 20th
century the care of children was shifted
from orphanages to foster families but
for many years
state and local government participation
in this field was quite limited
whether with or without governmental
participation catholic foster agencies
in philadelphia and other cities have a
long record of finding homes for
children
whose parents are unable or unwilling to
care for them
recently however the city has barred
catholic social services from continuing
this work because the catholic church
continues to believe that marriage is a
bond between one man and one woman
css will not vet same-sex couples as far
as the record reflects
no same-sex couple has ever approached
css but if that were to occur css would
simply refer the couple to another
agency that is happy to provide that
service there are at least 20
27 other such agencies in philadelphia
that didn't matter to philadelphia they
wanted
to crack down on css
regrettably the court declines to
confront employment division versus
smith
says alito instead it reverses based on
what appears to be a superfluous
and likely to be short-lived feature of
the city's standard annual contract with
foster care agencies
smith's holding about categorical rules
does not apply if a rule permits
individualized exemptions
and the majority seizes on the presence
of the city's standard of contract of
language
giving a city official the power to
grant exemptions the city tells us it
has never granted such an exemption and
has no intention of handing one to css
but the majority reverses the decision
below because the contract supposedly
confers that never use power
that decision might as well be written
on the dissolving paper sold in magic
shops the city has been adamant about
pressuring css to give in
if the city wants to get around today's
decision it can simply eliminate the
never used exemption power if it does
that
voila today's decision will vanish and
the parties will be back where
they started this is exactly right and
this is why i am super
mad at justice thomas this is what at
justice
roberts rather justice roberts
has been disgracefully committed to the
idea that the
the role of the supreme court in
american public life
in terms of how many people respect it
is significantly more important
than the actual protection of the
constitution of the united states
and that is simply wrong okay and again
as alito points out
the the employment division versus smith
notion
basically discriminates on the basis of
freedom of religion in a way that it
simply would not allow
for any other amendment in american law
right this this particular this
particular decision was an opportunity
it was a blown opportunity it was blown
because roberts who's the chief justice
and has the ability to do so decided to
cobble together a unanimous decision
rather than simply cobble together a
solid majority decision that
actually protected religious freedom in
a time when religious freedom is
seriously under assault
that is a huge crazy mistake
it's it's a and again it's not a mistake
by roberts because
this is what roberts thinks the court is
there to do basically i pulled the whim
of the legislature
and when you can't do it then you redraw
the law or you find some very narrow
excuse to strike down the law
allowing the the legislature or in this
case the city
council of philadelphia to go back and
rewrite the law allowing them to do
exactly
what they want a second time around what
a failure roberts has been
and what a disgrace to the supreme court
this is
it really is a bad decision in the same
way that the masterpiece cake shop
decision was a bad decision and has led
to the unending harassment
of again jack phillips
it's going to get worse guys if
employment vision versus smith is upheld
you will see that the sort of
anti-discrimination law
that is now being promoted by the city
of philadelphia and is common in cities
across the nation
is going to be used to crack down on any
religious organization that engages in
any sort of
activity that crosses streams with the
government's authority
i've said for a long time i think that
it is very much in the near future that
in places like california
tax-exempt status for religious schools
is going to be removed
accreditation for religious schools will
be removed
i think that is not a question of if i
think it is merely a question of when
and i think the answer
is pretty soon and the supreme court
could have stopped all that
they decided not to because justice
roberts is is too concerned with his own
vision
of of unanimity and upholding the
institutional quote-unquote integrity of
the court
while completely undermining that
integrity because again the court is in
fact
supposed to be it is its job to be an
anti-quote democratic
piece of constitutional machinery
defending fundamental rights under the
constitution if it doesn't do that it's
not doing its damn job
and that is exactly what happened here
already in just a second
controversy breaks out over juneteenth
first let me tell you about
how to relieve your car sickness okay so
my wife gets carsick regularly
whenever we're driving just starts
feeling yucky my sister same thing
so i got them a solution i'm talking
about relief ban relief ban
is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraines hangovers morning
sickness chemotherapy and so
much more honestly it's like a magic
thing it's so cool
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
provides
all natural relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to relieve
nausea for patients
now through relief band it's available
to the masses relief ban stimulates a
nerve on the wrist it travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you
you're sick
relief ben is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that has been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting and it definitely
works i've seen it work
on my wife my sister raves about relief
band it is that good
as the world is opening back up don't
let fear of nausea keep you on the
sidelines right now
relief ban has an exclusive offer just
for ben shapiro listeners go to
reliefband.com use promo code shapiro
you will receive
20 off plus free shipping no questions
asked 30-day money-back guarantee head
on over to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com reliefband.com use our promo
code shapiro get 20
off plus free shipping already it is
that time of the week
when i give a shout out to a daily wear
member today it's sharon b on twitter
who knows how to battle
these hot florida days in this picture
sharon and her daughters are striking a
cheerful pose
in front of cinderella's castle while
displaying the world's most elite
beverage vessel yes the caption reads
staying hydrated with leftist tears at
the happiest
wokest place on earth visiting disney's
magic kingdom with my twins for their
birthday hashtag leftist tears tumbler
fantastic that is some solid momming
right there and a happy belated birthday
to your daughters as well thanks for the
pic
thanks for being a daily wire member
also
i have an exciting announcement for you
today it all starts with october 15
1991 that is the day the united states
senate voted 52 to 48 to confirm
clarence thomas to the highest court in
the land however
while that was an incredible fee for any
american he fought harder than most to
accomplish it
in the documentary created equal we are
showing clarence thomas's rise from the
segregated south
to associate justice of the supreme
court one of the most important justices
in supreme court history and the all-out
war that was waged on him by anita hill
and the left during his confirmation now
amazon has removed
the historic and moving documentary they
actually took it down during black
history month
the daily wire has decided to step in we
have acquired the north american
streaming right
that's right you'll be able to add
created equal to your daily wire queue
so get ready it is streaming live
tonight at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central
for all daily wire members over at
dailywire.com
if you're not yet a daily wire member
join now with code justice for 20 off
your membership get ready
for a live stream unlike any other take
a look at the trailer
i was never going to be white the
problem is i could never go back
completely to the world i came from
[Music]
i saw what i had become and i asked god
and if you take
anger out of my heart i'll never hate
again you're not really black because
you're not doing what we expect black
people to do
that's when all heck broke loose so
you'd still like to serve on the supreme
court
i'd rather die than withdraw from the
process
[Music]
it's a really really solid piece of
filmmaking and it tells one of the most
important stories in modern american
life let me just tell you if
clarence thomas had been on the left you
can guarantee there are already been
biopics about him
right they do it for ginsburg but the
left just refuses to even acknowledge
that clarence thomas exists
exists we do not he's a super important
figure you can stream created equal live
tonight
at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central at
dailywire.com if you're not yet a daily
wear member join with codejustice for 20
off your membership get created equal
and all of our other great content like
my interview today
the man behind that documentary michael
pack airing shortly on the ben shapiro
show
special hour you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile congress declared
nearly unanimously
in favor of the idea of a juneteenth
holiday right a holiday that celebrates
the anniversary in 1865 of
slaves in texas being notified of the
emancipation proclamation it's been
celebrated as a texas holiday for
decades
and the the basic idea is that there
should be a holiday that commemorates
the end of slavery in the united states
which
seems pretty good to me considering the
united states sacrificed several hundred
thousand men
in order to end slavery in fact no less
a person interested in donald trump
last year called for juneteenth to
become a national holiday the only
reason it didn't is because there were a
few republican objections to
sort of the fiscal impact of that there
was talk about are there too many
federal holidays and all of that
okay bottom line is it passed 100
nothing in the senate right every
senator voted in favor of making
juneteenth the national holiday
everybody in the house except for i
think 14 republicans who had sort of
similar
concerns about too many federal holidays
everybody else voted in favor of
juneteenth as a national holiday and
then joe biden signed it into law
now this has caused controversy on two
separate scores
on the one side you have some people on
the right and they're basically just
reacting to people on the left
is the truth what what's happening is
that people on the left are saying
that because juneteenth now exists you
must acquiesce
to all of our legislative wishes so you
don't understand the legacy of
juneteenth
unless you're fine with critical race
theory unless you want hr one
unless you want all the things we want
you are dishonoring juneteenths they're
treating june team the way they treat
black history a month right oh it's
black and well during black history
month you definitely have to be in favor
of anything stacey abrams says it's
black history month
the left does the same thing with pride
month it's pride month how could ron
desantis
sign a law in florida saying that only
girls should play in girls sports during
pride month
how dare he same sort of thing happening
immediately upon the declaration of
juneteenth as a national holiday and the
answer to that is
juneteenth is a national holiday not
just a black holiday
because juneteenth is a celebration of
america fulfilling founding promises in
the declaration of independence as
lincoln spoke it has been celebrated for
decades for good reason
america is a magnificent place and
juneteenth is evidence that america
continues to progress
i mean how many civilizations in history
have had hundreds of thousands of men go
out and fight
to liberate other human beings not many
the answer is not very many
okay that the the the outcome of the
civil war and the emancipation of slaves
in the united states
and granting a full citizenship rights
to slaves
is an amazing development in american
history and is worthy of celebration
and by the way it should be a reminder
that it was the republican party as
always that freed the slaves it was not
the democratic party which opposed that
in any case
the the left has reacted with almost a
sort of
pathological theory at the fact that so
many conservatives seem okay with
juneteenth like they don't understand
why
and then there are people on the right
who see what the left is doing and
they're like well if you give them an
inch they'll take a mile so you should
have posed juneteenth on the basis
that juneteenth is divisive because the
left is using it to be divisive how
about this
juneteenth is unifying and the left
sucks how about that both of those
things can be simultaneously true
juneteenth should be a point of
unification because it is a great and
glorious moment in american history
that should be celebrated and also the
left sucks and is going to use any
opportunity in order to club people into
submission
okay so we saw some of this from joe
biden yesterday so joe biden he uh he
announced
he signed the bill into law that
juneteenth is now a federal holiday
and then he said but we have to do more
right and this is where the right starts
reacting well maybe we shouldn't have
given him june
you're not giving him juneteenth okay
juneteenth is a celebration of america
it's not a celebration of joe biden's
stupid agenda but here is joe biden
trying to make it into a celebration of
his stupid agenda
the truth is it's not simply not enough
just to commemorate
juneteenth after all
emancipation of enslaved black americans
didn't mark the end of america's work to
deliver on the promise of equality
it only marked the beginning to honor
the true meaning of juneteenth
we have to continue toward that promise
because we've not gotten there yet
the vice president and i and our entire
administration and all of you in this
room
are committed to doing just that
right so this is why you're seeing a
backlash american politics is so
reactionary i mean it's true everywhere
but it's so true in american politics
people cannot hold two thoughts at once
so there are a bunch of people on the
left they're like if you like june teen
then you have to embrace critical race
theory that's literally
an article that was leading huffington
post yesterday by a woman named taran
finley
called the hypocrisy of honoring
juneteenth while condemning critical
race theory
america has found itself at a
contradictory point in history yet again
on tuesday the senate unanimously passed
a bill to make juneteenth the day that
marked the end of enslavement in the
united states on june 19
1865 a federal holiday i mean that's not
actually
historically correct actually what
juneteenth was an announcement in
two years after the emancipation
proclamation two slaves in texas that
they were free
um but that that was actually i mean if
you want to talk about the actual end of
slavery in the united states you have to
talk about the 13th amendment to the
constitution in any case
this person argues social media users
have pointed out
how the irony the irony of lawmakers
overwhelming support for making
juneteenth the federal holiday compared
to their stalled approach to fighting
current racial discrimination
and injustice including through the john
lewis voting rights act
ah yes unless you believe everything the
left believes you're not allowed to
celebrate juneteenth
hey how dare how dare you it's just
terrible
i mean you have to respect critical race
theory and believe that all of america's
institutions
are underscored and and deeply
intertwined with racism
now it seems to me that juneteenth is
actually a pretty forcible rebuttal to
that the constitution of the united
states was actively
changed via the amendment process in
order to get rid of slavery
it was working within the legal
processes of the united states this is
that the civil rights act
was passed right it is the processes and
liberties guaranteed by the declaration
of
of independence and the constitution
that have allowed for the massive change
that has led to racial equality in the
united states
right like that that's all within the
system so if those systems are so bad
then why is it that we were able to
alleviate so many of these problems
within
the system in fact juneteenth is a
celebration of the system being upheld
right if the system had not been upheld
then you would have two separate
countries in the united states okay but
again the left-wing point of view is
that you're not allowed to celebrate
18th
unless you also embrace everything we
want you to embrace eugene robinson at
the washington post says the same thing
says making juneteenth the anniversary
of the day news of emancipation finally
reached enslaved people in galveston
texas national holidays a victory but
it's a hollow victory
at a moment when the political party
that won the civil war and made that
freedom a permanent reality
is now moving heaven and earth to keep
african americans from voting again
that's just
a lie okay no one is trying to stop
black people from voting
there is no vote there is no good
evidence of widespread voter suppression
or even moderate voter suppression
in the united states it is all a lie
it's just as much of a lie as the notion
that elections are being stolen
on a wide scale with hundreds of
millions of votes being like
the same people who are yelling to the
moon about how biden legitimately won
and anybody who questions that is a big
problem they're saying
voter suppression is being promulgated
every single day
without any evidence and joe biden lies
about this kind of crap so here is joe
biden lying about it while pushing
genting
it's not going to be fulfilled so long
as the sacred
right to vote remains under attack from
restrictive laws
threats of intimidation voter purges and
more
an assault that offends the very
democracy our very democracy we can't
rest so the promise of equality is
fulfilled for every one of us
in every corner of this nation that to
me
is the meaning of juneteenth right the
meaning of juneteenth is do what i want
right and so the predictable result has
been from some on the right okay well
what if we just don't do what you want
and we don't give you juneteenth
and the answer is you're not again
you're not giving joe biden juneteenth
juneteenth has been an american holiday
in texas for many many years
because it is a celebration of america
america
freed its slaves america promulgated
racial equality
the richest black people on planet earth
live in america
average household income for black
americans is higher than average
household income for black people
anywhere on the planet
okay this is a wonderful wonderful
country juneteenth is a celebration of
that the left
thinks juneteenth is a celebration of
how america sucks and so the right some
a few people i'd say the segment to the
right is reacting to that by saying
well if they say america sucks based on
juneteenth let's just not do juneteenth
it's all just reactionary ping-ponging
okay but you can see the left pushing
this kind of crap and it's insane
okay you have aoc doing the same thing
it's essentially tying juneteenth to
critical race theory he said oh the
reason that people
are denying juneteenth is because they
also deny critical race theory what if i
what if i
like the idea of celebrating the end of
slavery and also think critical race
theory is bunk
in part because we ended slavery here's
aoc being uh her normal
genius itself whether it's trying to
fight against teaching
basic history around racism and the role
of racism
in u.s history to you know there's a
direct
through line from that to denying
juneteen
the day that wheat that is widely
recognized and celebrated
as the symbolic kind of day that to
represent the end of slavery in the
united states
you know there's a direct through line
between that denial of our history and
wanting to understand the full scope of
our history
and celebrating the end a major end of
injustice
in the united states okay so what the
left is lying about the left is lying
what they're lying about is they are
tying
juneteenth to critical race theory
they're saying they're one in the same
so you can't do one without the other
and the right some on the right say okay
well fine so we won't do either
and the answer is no two things can be
true at once juneteenth is good and
critical race theory is bad
that is very easy to do okay it also
happens to be the truth
and you know you fight you can see the
game the left is playing here and it's
really a
quite despicable game again taking
elements of american history that should
unify
us like you know america ending slavery
and turning it into a point of division
in order to suggest that all of
america's institutions are hierarchical
in nature and must be torn to the ground
and the fact is that i i will
acknowledge i am amazed at the extent to
which critical race theory
has taken over our institutions truly
it's amazing
perfect example so this week
there was a a questioning for chief of
naval operations admiral michael gilday
the chief of naval operations had put
out a list
of recommended books to members of the
navy including ibram x kennedy's
garbage fascist tyrannical racist book
how to be anti-racist it is a piece of
crap that book it is a terrible terrible
book
again not calling for its suppression
because i believe in free speech
you should read the book and then you
should recognize how stupid it is okay
but
being recommended in america's military
a a book that basically argues that
america is inevitably and inherently
racist
and evil and that active discriminatory
measures must be taken today
okay so admiral gilray or gilday rather
was questioned by republican study
committee chairman jim banks and he
defended all this he said no it's very
good
we need critical race theory needs to be
taught to the members of america's
military
now it needs to be fought in america's
military is what needs to happen
admiral why did you put this book on the
reading list and recommend it to
every single united states sailor read
it because i think it's really important
to consider
a variety of views you said you read
this book what part of this book is
redeeming
and and qualifies as something that that
every
every sailor is about his own journey
as an african-american in this country
what he's experienced
let me ask you again admiral do you
expect
that say after sailors read this book
that says that the united states navy is
racist
that we will increase or decrease morale
cohesion and recruiting race into the
united states navy
i think we'll be a better navy from
having open
honest conversations about racism
it's not an open honest conversation
about racism and this is the lie that
people
who have now wormed their way into the
heights of all of america's institutions
continue to promulgate this stuff this
is why and by the way it's just honestly
it's an avoidance technique
for so many members of the left who
don't want to govern and be good at
their jobs it's an avoidance technique
you suck at your job and so you blame
racism and talk about how
racism is the big specter out there
lurking that is causing you to suck at
your job this is what mario lori
lightfoot is doing mayor lori light for
the garbage mayor of chicago
shootings have been out of control under
lori lightfoot she's allowed people to
just ransack chicago's loop she's awful
in every respect
but there is a public health crisis she
says the public health crisis in chicago
way for a way for it's
racism almost every single point in our
city's history
sadly racism has taken a devastating
toll
on the health and well-being of our
residents of color
and particularly those who are black
and without formally acknowledging this
history and reality
and the continuing impact of that
infamous legacy
looking at the root causes of today's
challenges
we will never be able to move forward as
a city and fully provide
our communities with the resources that
we need
to live happy vibrant and fulfilled
lives
that's why ladies and gentlemen i am
here today
with racial equity and healthcare
leaders to formally declare
systemic racism as a public health
crisis
here in chicago
okay all that is a way to avoid
governing that's all it is
okay so again celebrate the country by
celebrating the good
that it does and recognize that the left
will always attempt to use everything as
a club to beat you into submission
and and that's what the left is doing
today it's why the left can't just take
the win
it's not even a win for them it's why
the left can't just accept the
unification of juneteenth and instead
tries to turn it immediately
into a divisive issue about the
continuing evils of the united states
which by the way is a message
directly contrary to the message of
actually juneteenth
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show first
you can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so head
on over to dailywire.com
this evening 7pm eastern 6 pm central
tune in i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin